d'accord,
je suis venu de la Louisiane négative
parce que nous voulions venir faire l'expérience de
cela à Los Angeles, je vais normalement aux jeux
mais comme je ne pouvais pas vraiment aller voir
physiquement juste être ici,
c'est incroyable qu'ils aient dû le faire pour kobe
euh il  n'est pas venu ici pour prendre la place de kobe
il est venu ici pour aider à remettre cette
franchise sur la carte le remettre dans les
séries éliminatoires vous savez
revenir au championnat auquel nous appartenons
donc
je respecte lebron james pour cela je
veux juste dire merci  lebron pour l'
avoir ramené pour kobe mec je t'aime
mec
ça fait longtemps ça fait 10 ans
et
euh beaucoup beaucoup de gens tu sais donna
lebron une fois qu'il est venu ici
je n'étais pas sur le bronze pour être honnête
jusqu'à ce que nous ayons  ici mais je suis un
fan de longue date des lakers depuis que je suis
un jeune enfant, donc très excité les
champions des lakers un de plus
[Musique]
toi